now look at this this is like when I was
a kid out of baseball cards Willie Mays
and Hank Aaron science equivalent of
that yeah okay
so first question for both you guys is
it worth engaging with people who deny
facts like evolution and climate change
is it worth just engaging he's got more
patience for that we have to do it we
have to do it it's it is worth it
because we've got to I mean that's if
right don'twe I agree we're screwed
yeah but I think but but we have
different tactics regarding that and and
I think there's a way to lames me all
your fault no I think there's I think
you want to offer them this way of
thinking about the natural world and
then they come to it on their own rather
than sort of tack him what and they
don't feel stupid what about the way I
read that biography of don regan about
ronald reagan and like you know reagan
was not very engaged about stuff but
they would get him engaged they'd be
like he'd go into reagan's office and
say do you know what three companies in
america have in common
they all don't and then Reagan be like
no what well here's a jelly bean and
they draw a little soldier and then they
draw a great big soldier right I wish I
was making that up it was anecdotal he
didn't care about AIDS until Rock Hudson
got it and I was like Oh Rock Hudson I
know him yeah I guess so he came so the
circumstances were set up so that he
came to the problem rather than beat him
over headed for some sometimes you got
to leave the bread crumbs is all I'm
saying
but if I may wouldn't you agree Richard
that when you think about Darwin I know
as a hero to both of you guys right he
sort of broke up the labour Darwin
himself was very non polemical he never
he never made those kinds of arguments
but he let Huxley he legend I mean he
was a good cop yeah exactly
Neal Neal's the Darwin oh I'll be the
Alpha Sox all right
the division of labor so you're the
Lenin and you're the truck you're gonna
Laden in here this hour you know Willie
Mays in your hang down okay but maybe
other people I hear selves why must you
wear that vest
we can ask why all right uh wait wait
best wait ahead one trail for Angela
okay will the democratic debate there's
a democratic debate we forget about the
Denver Republicans so suck up all the
air what when is it I'm 13 I'm droppin
ready to say my mother's birthday oh
sorry no you're okay you're good to go
you followed it that closely no it's
just information it's knowledge she's
just mad at that the folks running for
office and not the electorate right yeah
I am
well you know I'm not I must defend
myself I'm the one guy in TV who's
consistently said the American people
are buckets do I've gotten so much [ __ ]
about it over the years I don't know
what's will Blitzer like we're rating
are you really saying Americans are
stupid I'm like yes wolf
I am so yeah but don't tell yeah but but
the task of the educator is not to tell
their students that they're stupid I'm
not attacking the educator is to wait
have them come to a point of enlightened
man out where they embrace end it off to
you that's why you're the good guy right
ignition well the democratic debate help
candidates like Jim Webb or martin
O'Malley um good luck with that what I
would say honestly what I would say um
would help them is I don't really know
what would help them at this point
actually um I think that they're not
doing it for this year they're doing a
future yeah but I think Martin O'Malley
had a good run as governor of Maryland
he's had a very hard time getting any
traction in this election I think
Hillary Clinton came in is very
formidable and now folks aren't looking
to martin O'Malley as the Challenger
they're really looking at Bernie Sanders
who is kind of big
aren't even a few by Bernie Sanders
candidacy are looking to see window
vital into the race is he going to I
don't know
very still out I heard he was I haven't
seen anything yet we had to bet your own
money well would you say I would say yes
really I would really I would Wow I
doubt know what you're right you're
right because why would he you know all
this came from him it had to why would
he stir this process the first time in
his life that he's ever registered a
pulse in a national political poll
running for president right started
running for president I think when I was
12 right first time and never even had
like 1% anywhere but now suddenly the
Brydon trial balloon gets him like at 20
Sophia he's gonna be like mom okay um
should we be wary guys of the
developments in artificial intelligence
speaking of the Republican that's
natural stupidity uh well this is
something I've heard of him Warner even
musk is worried about I think Stephen
Hawking is why I'm actually quite
surprised that artificial intelligence
hasn't advanced further than it than it
has and in looking back to the nineteen
seventies when I first started taking an
interest in it I thought it would be
much further advanced by now anything
you see is well but when when you look
at so many of the things that were in
science fiction movies back then we
thought we'd have flying cars now you
know we kind of do their coal
helicopters but yeah that is not a
flying well it goes up and it goes down
it's the kind of noise a flying car
would make so that's why we don't have
flying cars because it would be really
noisy and blow all kinds of things off
of the street when it came up and down
that's one thing but I disagree with
Elon Musk and
and Steven Harkin I have no fear of
artificial intelligence because we were
already exposed to artificial
intelligence sure a computer beat us at
chess a game we invented we put our best
chess player the computer smoked him all
right we are computer our best jeopardy
player got smoked by another computer ok
and so it did was at the end of
civilization do people say oh my gosh
that will happen to us and this is been
going on since the Industrial Revolution
replacing our body computers replacing
our mind we've been doing it ever since
the beginning but you're cherry-picking
an easy example the chess game I mean
come on that that had holds no threat to
us but there are other things that would
the thing about chess is that it's a
domain which is very carefully defined
and and it's much more difficult to have
an artificial intelligence which can
handle anything you throw at it anything
in real life but it will come I'm sure
let me actually Richard can with
artificial intelligence mimicking the
human mind we have a lot of neurological
baggage from our evolutionary past is
that baggage which most of the time is
not functioning rationally or logically
is that the source of our creativity and
if that's the case now you program a
computer as complex as ever you do but
it's still according to a prescribed
code so can a computer ever be as
inventive as a human being you could
build in a certain random element and in
that would that would do it if it was so
program in the randomness yeah it but
but rat randomness filtered through some
interesting circuitry what could come
out as imaginative curiosity guys how to
do a buddy cop movie solve crimes
and the province of the United in cetera
Matt well jury as a libertarian are you
disappointed by Rand Paul's performance
in the campaign very much so I didn't
expect that his floor would be as low as
this has been I thought he would had
like 10% going in but Ruiz he was
pulling at you know three four months
ago but he he being you know didn't
stand up for what he believed in I did
the problem here I think he had a twin
daddy problem and I don't mean that
Nisour the George Bush like biological
sense but in that Ron Paul's most
passionate followers don't like Rand
Paul they think he's a big sell out and
I do you mean he did us a opened his
campaign in front of an aircraft carrier
his father would have never done that
his father was saying we got to get rid
of this [ __ ] and this guy was saying I'm
embracing it and he I know what's his
constituency now he's just like one of
the other 12 beers I think I think
there's something too bad I mean in the
last debate you saw him actually bring
the only kind of foreign policy critique
there on the stage saying hey we can't
just keep going to war every single time
he also made some really good of
discussion about marijuana put Chris
Christie right for on the defensive
about the kind of monstrous application
of the drug war that he and basically
most everybody else on that stage I've
used and there was a little bit of a
pickup in the in the Paul universe the
question is can enough people kind of
finally quit in this race so that so
that there can be you know Bob wise
Bobby Jindal still running we don't know
right there's a path but the path is
pretty small I think all right what is
currently the most exciting area of
scientific development the origin of
life is something we don't know anything
about and we want to know something
about it and I would love to know how
life actually got started that the
origin of the first self-replicating
entity I'm not a biologist and that's my
top three things as well does how do you
go from organic molecules to
self-replicating life that happened in
the early earth and it happened
relatively quickly very shortly after
could have possibly happened
it happened maybe this has been brought
up before but lightning hit it well you
know that was if you guys thought of
that I mean that was a nice article
Eamon you know fresh eyes on a problem
yeah you know years ago they did that
experiment they built a boat he knew
that right on cue primordial soup
educated they build a boat a bowl of
primordial soup and they put a electric
charge through it and then they found
that actually that organic root oh but
that wasn't necessary just doing that I
not we now know how yes but the
righty-right contained that but as very
same organic molecules which which
Miller made is by his lightnings yes yes
so that you get them for free but still
just organic chemistry and at the end of
the day you want to have
self-replicating life and that's a
mystery also we don't know it was around
before the Big Bang that's kind of fun
we have some ideas maybe a multi version
with one of multiple bubbles of
universes coming in and out of existence
we did just pull that out of an orifice
that's an cogent extrapolation of the
marriage of quantum physics and
relativity also is there life elsewhere
in the universe especially in a backyard
like in the subsurface soils of Mars I
got a good question for you answer my
question because interstellar yeah you
saw that yeah of course okay okay so
it's scared by the five lead actors all
have starred in their own film and they
all play scientist and engineers and
they're fully fleshed out characters
rather than the weird wire-haired lab
coat donning person that you don't care
anything about except will we survive
this attack they were fully fan I think
that was a first in blockbuster films
that scientists could be treated as just
ordinary characters that just happen to
know more about something than others
did and but Matthew McConaughey was
really not that credible aside it was
still like we have to wait to go
through the black hole alright alright
here's my question
because I mean the reason why they have
to find a new place to live is because
there's a horrible drought on earth
nothing's growing anymore yeah and we've
had a horrible drought here in
California and I look at it and you know
we don't really know when the tipping
point for global warming is going to get
to that point where maybe California is
the whole world so if that happens
here's the problem if you find another
planet yeah any planets we have any
record of they're very unlike earth so
you're gonna have to learn how to
terraform other planets turn them into
something like earth and then you have
to ship a billion people there this is
so so Stephen Hawking wants us to be a
multi-planet species so that one the
species doesn't go extinct by something
bad happening in one place my rebuttal
to that is if you have the power to turn
another planet into Earth then you have
the power to turn earth back into earth
you
you